in the last video we were able to
calculate the total sum of squares for
these nine data points right here and
these nine data points are grouped into
three different groups or if we want to
speak generally into M different groups
what I want to do in this video is to
figure out how much of this total sum of
squares how much of this is due to
variation within each group versus
variation between the actual groups so
first let's figure out the total
variation within the group so let's call
that the sum of squares within so let's
calculate the sum of squares within and
I'll do that in yellow next we already
used yellow so let's do this let me do
blue so the sum of squares within sum of
squares within let me make it clear that
stands for within within so we want to
see how much of the variation is due to
how far each of these data points are
from their central tendency from their
respective means so this is going to be
equal to let's start with these guys so
instead of taking the distance between
each data point and the mean of means
I'm going to find the distance between
each data point and that groups mean
because we want to square the total the
total of the total sum of squares
between each data point and their
respective means so let's do that so
it's 3 minus the mean here is 2 squared
plus 2 minus 2 squared plus 2 minus 2
squared plus 1 minus 2 squared 1 minus 2
squared plus I'm going to do this for
all of the groups but for each group the
distance between each data point at its
mean so plus 5 minus 4 plus 5 minus 4
squared plus 4 or minus 4 squared sorry
the next number was 3 plus 3 minus 4
squared plus 4 minus 4 squared and then
finally we have the third group we're
finding the tall of the sum of squares
from each point to its central tendency
within that but we're going to add them
all up and then we find the third group
so we have 5 minus oh it's it's me 2 6 5
- six squared plus 6 minus 6 squared
plus 7 minus 6 squared and what is this
going to equal so this is going to be
equal to up here it's going to be 1 plus
0 plus 1 so that's going to be equal to
2 plus and this is going to be equal to
1 1 plus 1 plus 0 so another 2 plus this
is going to be equal to 1 plus 0 plus 1
7 minus 6 is 1 squared is 1 so plus so
that's 2 over here so this is going to
be equal to our total our sum of squares
within I should say is 6 so one way to
think about it our total variation was
30 and based on this calculation 6 of
that 36 of that 30 comes from variation
within these samples now the next thing
I want to think about is how much how
many degrees of freedom do we have in
this calculation how many kind of
independent data points do we actually
have well it for each of these so over
here if you know if you know like we
have n data points in each one in
particular n is 3 here but if you know
if you know n minus 1 of them you can
always figure out the nth one if you
know the actual sample mean so in this
case if for any of these groups if you
know two of these data points you can
always figure out the third if you know
these two you can always figure out the
third if you know the sample mean so in
general let's figure out the degrees of
freedom here you have for each group for
each group when you did this you had you
had n minus 1 degrees of freedom
remember n n is the number of the number
of data points you had in each group so
you have n minus 1 degrees of freedom
for each of these groups for each of
these groups so it's n minus 1 n minus 1
n minus 1 or you have let me put it this
way you have n minus 1 for each of these
groups and there are M groups and there
are M groups so there's M times n minus
1 degrees of freedom
degrees of freedom and in this case in
particular each group n minus one is two
or in each case you had two degrees of
freedom and there's three groups of that
so there are six degrees of freedom
there are six degrees of freedom I'm
going to write six degrees 6 degrees of
freedom and in the future we might do a
more detailed discussion of what degrees
of freedoms mean and how you know how to
mathematically think about it but the
best the simplest way to think about is
really truly independent data point
assuming you knew in this case the
central statistic that we use to
calculate the squared distance in each
of them if you know them already the
third data point could actually be
calculated from the other two so we have
6 degrees of freedom over here now that
was how much of the variation is due to
variation how much of the total
variation is due to variation within
each sample now let's think about how
much of the variation is due to
variation between between the samples
and to do that we're going to calculate
let me get a nice color here I think
I've run out of all the colors will call
the sum of squares sum of squares
between the B stands for between sum of
squares between the samples so another
way to think about it how much of this
total variation is due to the variation
between the means between the central
tendency that's what we're going to
calculate right now and how much is due
to variation from from each data point
to its mean so let's figure out how much
is due to variation between these guys
over here so if we one way to think
about it for for each of these data
points for each of the actually let's
think about just this first group for
this first group how much variation for
each of these guys is due to the
variation between this mean and the mean
of means and the mean of means well it's
going to be so this for this first guy
up here I'll just write it all out
explicitly the variation is going to be
its sample mean so it's going to be to
minus the mean of means squared and then
for this guy is going to be the same
thing his sample mean to minus the mean
of mean squared plus the same thing for
this guy to - the me
of mean squared or another way to think
about it this is equal to this is equal
to I'll write it over here
this is equal to three times two minus
four squared which is the same thing as
three this is equal to 3 times 3 times 4
3 times 4 is equal to 12 and then we
could do it for each of them and
actually I wanted to find the total sum
so let me just write it all out actually
I think that might be an easier thing to
do because I want to find that for all
of these guys combined the sum of
squares due to the differences between
the samples so that's from the first
sample the contribution from the first
sample and then from the second sample
you have this guy over here 5 oh sorry
you sure you don't want to calculate him
for this data point the amount of
variation due to the difference between
the means is going to be 4 minus 4 it's
going to be 4 minus 4 squared same thing
for this guy it's going to be 4 minus 4
squared we're not picking it into
consideration we're only taking its
sample mean into consideration and then
finally plus 4 minus 4 squared we're
taking this minus this squared for each
of these data points and then finally
we'll do that with the last group with
the last group sample mean is 6 so it's
going to be 6 minus 4 squared plus 6
minus 4 squared plus 6 minus 4 plus 6
minus 4 squared now let's think about
how many how many degrees of freedom we
had in this calculation right over here
how many degrees of freedom well in
general the I guess the easiest way to
think about is how many kind of how much
information did we have assuming that we
knew the mean of means if we know the
mean Amin's how much here is new
information
well we if you know two of these if you
know the mean of the mean and you know
two of these sample means you can always
figure out the third if you know this
one in this one you can figure out that
one if you know that one in that one you
can figure out that one and that's
because this is the mean of these means
over here so in general if you have M if
you have M groups or if you have M means
there are M minus one
of freedom here so there's M minus 1
degrees of freedom here let me write
that there are M minus 1 degrees of
freedom but with that said well in this
case M is 3 so we could say we could say
there's two degrees of freedom two
degrees of freedom for this exact
example let's actually let's calculate
the sum of squares between so what is
this going to be this is going to be
equal to I'll just scroll down running
out of space this is going to be equal
to this right here is 2 minus 4 is
negative 2 squared is 4 and then we have
three fours over here so it's 3 times 4
plus 3 times 3 times what is this 3
times 0 3 times 0 plus what is this
the difference between each of these 6
minus 4 is 2 squared is 4 so we have 3
times 4 plus 3 times 4 and we get 3
times 4 is 12 plus 0 plus 12 is equal to
is equal to 24 24 so the sum of squares
or we could say the variation due to
what's the difference between the groups
between the means is 24 now let's put it
all together we said that the total the
total variation the total variation that
if you look at all 9 data points is 30
let me write that over here so the sum
of squares the total sum of squares is
equal to 30 we figured out the sum of
squares between each data point and its
central tendency its sample mean we
figured out it and we totaled it all up
we got 6 so the sum of squares the sum
of squares within the sum of squares
within was equal to 6 and in this case
it was 6 degrees of freedom and we also
had 6 degrees of freedom or if we wanted
to write it generally there were M times
n minus 1 degrees of freedom and
actually for the total we figured out we
had M times n minus 1 degrees of freedom
we had M times n minus 1 degrees of
freedom actually let me just write
degrees of freedom in this column right
over here in this case this was actually
the number
turned out to be eight and then just now
we calculated the sum of squares between
the samples the sum of squares between
the samples is equal to 24 and we
figured out that it had M minus 1
degrees of freedom which ended up being
2 now the whole the interesting thing
here and that's this is why this kind of
analysis of variance all fits nicely
together and in future videos we'll
we'll think about how we can actually
test hypotheses using some of the tools
that were thinking about right now is
that the sum of squares within plus the
sum of squares between is equal to the
total sum of squares so a way to think
about it is that the total variation the
total variation in this data right here
can be described as the sum of the
variation within each of these groups
when you take that total plus the sum of
the variation between the groups between
the groups and even the degrees of
freedom work out this has the sum of
squares between had two degrees of
freedom the sum of squares within each
of the groups had six degrees of freedom
2 plus 6 is 8 that's the total degrees
of freedom we had in art fart for all of
the data combined it even works if you
look at the the more general so our sum
of squares between had M minus 1 degrees
of freedom our sum of squares within had
M times n minus 1 degrees of freedom so
this is equal to M minus 1 plus MN minus
M these guys cancel out this is equal to
MN minus 1 degrees of freedom which is
exactly the total degrees of freedom we
had for the total sum of squares so the
whole point of the calculations that we
did in the last video and in this video
is just to appreciate that this total
variation that this total variation over
here this total variation that we first
calculated can be viewed as the sum of
these kind of two component variations
how much variation is there between each
of the samples versus how much variation
oh sorry how much variation is there
within each of the samples plus how much
variation is there between the means of
the samples hopefully that's not too
confusing